bees have well-ordered societies
enabling them to produce goods for the
well-being of the hive pollinating
plants they generate products and
harmony with nature a real balance
between the environment economy and
society this is what we call sustainable
development important for today's and
future harvests and at risk of
disappearing
bees have alerted us that the balance is
harmed to ensure quality of life for our
own and future generations we need to
keep this balance so how is the EU doing
on its way to keeping it
Eurostat helps to answer this question
with its monitoring reports and
sustainable development in the EU here
are some findings from the 2013 edition
economic activity has recovered partly
from the crisis for the outlook remains
uncertain overall the growth was 11.2%
between 2000 and 2012 the EU is close to
its aim of having a 20% share of
renewable energy
it seems we managed to use less
resources in our economy but it's not
clear if this is a real efficiency gain
or a short-lived effect of the crisis
restrictions partly also due to the
crisis greenhouse gas emissions have
dropped placing Europe on track to have
reduced emissions by 20% by 2020 however
we have been constantly overfishing with
the crisis the number of people at risk
of poverty and social exclusion rose to
124 million in 2012 including twenty
five point five million children this
takes the EU away from its aim to lift
20 million people out of poverty
by 2020 on a positive note the life
expectancy of newborns has increased
though longer lives mean also an aging
Society the good news is that the
employment of older people keeps rising
it's complex but interesting isn't it we
monitor this mixed picture for
sustainable development in Europe with
more than 100 indicators including
distance to targets of EU s growth
strategy culture of 2020 to give you a
quick picture of this complexity we use
weather symbols our data is available
for everyone to explore I hope you will
use these statistics for your everyday
decisions and exercise of your
democratic rights
you